bonjour à toutes et bienvenue
aujourd'hui d'europe et donc puisque
nous accueillons michel barnier
bonjour allons jouer je remercie être
avec nous sur le plateau d'europe et
d'eau
alors le temps se chargera rapporte fait
très important commissaire hors charge
du marché intérieur et le service
himmich et barnier vous avez reçu avec
les 26 autres commissaires européens
françois hollande qui est venu haute
devant la commission
européenne sert aussi à ça se passe
très rarement la dernière fois
c'était en en 1997 avec jacques chirac
est-ce que françois hollande qui est
venu parler de la politique française
est-ce qu'il a été
convaincant
which d'abord serrar que le présent le
public vienne
l'an dernier c'était jacques chirac le
premier est français était venu
françois fillon
et puis c'est pas rare pour les autres
dirigeants européens madame merkel est
venue participer à un déjeuner de
travail et d'autres chefs d'état moi je
trouve ça très normal
le la commission nous sommes séparés
n'est pas étranger
nous sommes là au service de l'union
européenne des états membres
d autres institutions et donc c'est
très important que
pour les françaises viennent dialoguer
ça a été stream en direct
le commissionnaire 3 e
très sincère
c'est un examen c'est un gros on a
parlé d'un rallye tout mais la grande
chorale s'était pas du tout l'été
despite à l'esprit de cette réunion
c'était un dialogue entre eux par la
république
qui va expliquer sa politique
qui dit le sable sa foi
ericsson son espoir pour l'europe
légalement son souci de
le modifier et je peux comprendre ça
parce que moi-même je suis revenu
abou sayyaf trois ans pour que l'om
retrouve
unicom avait abandonné que celle de
l'économie sociale de marché
plutôt que de se laisser
menée par sept ou huit l'idéologie
ultralibérale qui domine
dans le monde et art et eneurope depuis
30 ans
pendant que le plan public et nous
allons extrêmement clair
et on n'a pas de ce contrat puisqu'il
s'agit d'un contrat
deux de ses actes assainissements
budgétaires que la france doit faire
pour elle-même et c'est par brussels et
c'est pas
berlin a fait pas l'europe
c'est parce qu'on a trop de dette
pour les déficits
on va pas continuer
éternellement à dépenser plus
d'argent pour notre dette que pour
l'éducation de nos enfants
donc le caricaturer le contrat justement
célèbre tracé
ross a lâché en deux années de plus
souple en échange de contreparties on
voit bien que la france a besoin pour
à atteindre que les 3% de déficit au
confort pour elle-même pour faire moins
de déficit - dette
ne pas pénaliser les générations
futures
c'est d'ailleurs à pleurer en public
pendant l'intervention de calvaire
une caresse france avait recommandé ne
jamais sacrifier l'avenir au présent
et est maintenant nous sommes tous les
deux ans cette obligation de ne plus
sacrifier
l'avenir
les générations futures
à notre confort ou
un autre
la situation d'aujourd'hui
c'est ce que paris entendait se
cette plante est en effet révélé
mercredi que
nous nous
la france est engagée dans un programme
forme
certains éléments sont déjà là
notamment
ce qu'on appelle plus si sécurité du
marché du travail mais la nouvelle
réforme des retraites la réforme de
l'apprentissage voie des réformes qui
sont très importantes encore une fois
pour la france pour elle-même c'est pas
exemptés au nifff princesse
ces réformes pour les français ces
français qui peut le faire problème il
faudrait maintenant une première
question
en fait c'est un doute ici à bruxelles
sur ce qui est fait sur la capacité de
la france à se réformer on a un peu le
sentiment puis depuis quelques mois où
depuis même quelques années que
la france pourrait devenir assez
rapidement le maillon faible
e de l'europe or c'est la deuxième
économie européenne donc évidemment
c'est un impact est-ce que ce qu'il a
dit françois hollande est-ce que ça a
été de nature
pour rassurer
e les les commissaires européens dont
vous êtes et s'il ya un doute que
l'ipad aujourd'hui
on sait bien que la france est un pays
très centralisé
qui ne pratiquent pas le dialogue social
ne vous faites pas de réforme sans
dialogue social comment les allemands
font
les pays du nord de l'europe font c'est
parce qu'ils ont l'habitude de dialoguer
branche par branche entreprise par
entreprise avec des syndicats qui sont
respectés qu'ils sont forts
et donc en france il faut qu'on prenne
cette
habitudes
de de dialogue social
fond de court ne pourra pas réformé
et dans un tout autre genre de question
on a beau donner je pense que
pour la repubblica
j'étais extrêmement claire et
volontariste
dans ses engagements
de poursuivre
et d'amplifier le prendrait forme pour
la france est-ce que vous pensez michel
barnier que deux ans c'est suffisant
pour en effet âgé sauce ce changement
de cap
parce que c'est quand même de de
répondre importante dont il s'agit
est ce que la france est capable de
faire ce que ce cas ce qu'ont fait les
allemands par exemple une question de
volonté
c'est une question de courage politique
à la fois pour le gouvernement
qui va peut-être prendre des mesures
qui ne sont pas populaires
dans son électorat
et puis j'ajoute pour l'opposition
qui devra avoir le courage politique de
soutenir ces réformes
c'est le bronx
dans le sens que que que nous souhaitons
pour courage politique de tous les
côtés
mémé et deux ans oui c'est suffisant
sur ce revers a pas eu besoin de deux
ans pour tous
décidé d'un programme
françois fillon quand il a fait que
c'est sarkozy
la première réforme des retraites qui
n'est pas suffisant qu'il faut la
compléter pour la fête en moins de
deux ans ceux de michel sapin le
ministre français du cna il travaille
a fait une réforme en moins dede de six
mois sur eux le marché du travail donc
c'est possible qu'une question de
volonté et de courage politique
donc pour vous les réformes la
structure et prioritaires à mener pour
la france
f c'est d'abord les retraites le marché
du travail toute la joie à la fin de
compte elles sont en réalité contenues
dans un document que je crois très
important qui est le rapport de louis
gallois
louis gallois
c'est par bruxelles ni berlin qui lui a
demandé de faire ce rapport
c'est le gouvernement actuel c'est
françois hollande
toutes les faiblesses françaises
l'une de celle de la france
et notamment
la difficulté quand les entreprises
avoir des marges
à se développer parce qu'ils sont
écrasés par le le le poids des charges
il faut pas les juger le poids de ses
charges sur les entreprises notamment
les petites et moyennes entreprises
il faut réformer l'apprentissage
regardant ce que font les allemands
la formation correspond au travail
disponible
développer l'entrepreneuriat social
l'entrepreneuriat régionales
et l'entrepreneuriat familiale et
peut-être
avec des outils comme ce qu'on est en
train de créer des banques publiques il
est donc régional
le soutenir
alors michel barnier se passe beaucoup
de choses en grand pour ce moment
notamment m on a parlé du dossier
numéro un la lutte contre les paradis
il secolo elle est lancée eneurope mais
aussi dans le monde clé de voûte de
cette bataille-là enfants programmée
du secret bancaire on en parle avec vos
juste après ce sujet est signée
thibault le floch
serge
les réunions se succèdent à bruxelles
mais cette fois l'ordre du jour est
claire la lutte contre les paradis
fiscaux et devenu la priorité enfin
europe
lyon va à la proie d'un impératif
moral mme pillay a exigé
par l'opinion publique c'est aussi un
problème de finances publiques pour le
matériel économique chaque année dans
l'union européenne milliards d'euros
échappent à l'impôt
comment contrer la fraude en
généralisant les chances automatique
d'informations sur les revenus et le
capital au sein des états membres c'est
ce que propose la commission européenne
la fin du secret bancaire dans toute
l'union d'ici à 2015
la bataille est mondiale réunis près
de londres les ministres des finances
des sept pays les plus riches de la
planète frontzeck fischer quand front
unique contre l'évasion fiscale
et on le répète nous sommes tous
d'accord sur l'importance d'une action
collective pour lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale
avec lui
une enquête internationale a été
ouverte
les etats-unis le royaume-uni et
l'australie pour annoncer avoir
recueilli des milliers de données
informatiques sur des comptes secrets
détenue dans les trous noirs de la
finance mondiale
la masse d'informations dépasserait de
loin celle de l'offshoring christine
deux millions et demi de fichiers
révélée par un consortium de
journalistes
selon une source américaine les îles
vierges qu'alimenter concur seraient
visés par l'enquêté
c'est pour l'instant le seul élément
qui a filtré de ces documents
erdogan
alors michel barnier sur portage mac os
bien de voir un sentiment qu'on aurait
pu voir quasiment le même
il ya 20 ans on a l'impression que les
choses piétinant sens d'une volonté
politis de faire avancer les choses
impression que les choses piétinent
on voit des égoïsmes nationaux et des
pays comme l'autriche ou son bord bon
vous vous êtes commissaire européen
qu'est-ce que vous dites à ces pays la
guinée
nous on veut garder notre commentaire
les choses ont
piétiner pour une raison très précise
qu'il faut expliquer c'est que toutes
ces questions de fiscalité
ils sont gérés à l'unanimité
entre les mises des finances
pourquoi ministre
peut bloquer
et empêcher le mouvement des 26 autres
et c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé
mais jusqu'à maintenant
sauf que eux
ces produits depuis quelques semaines un
événement important avec ces fuites
massives
de listings les gens qui ont peur
utiliser
l'optimisation fiscale
donc utiliser ces paradis fiscaux plus
tout à fait exact qu'en france plus les
affaires prend par chaque pays comme
celle-ci
qui ont créé un nouvel état d'esprit
et nous sommes là nous connaissions pas
avec mon texte sur la table et nous
disons
pour voter
tous les textes ont été présentés
par mon collègue ses mutas contre les
paradis fiscaux
transparence pour le lieu change
de données et d'information outre les
banques automatique
moi-même j'ai présenté le texte
contre le blanchiment d argent
contre eux argent du crime
et tous ces attaques sont là il suffit
maintenant de les voter et ce que je
sens
y compris sur le secret bancaire
c'est tout le monde bouge
parce qu'il ya cette nouvelle ambiance
et puis aussi
parce que la crise fait que
le l'évasion fiscale est encore plus
insupportable encore plus scandaleuse
mille millards amis votre reportage oui
mais hier
je sais que mes meilleures
d'euros c'est le budget de l'union
européenne pour sept ans
je pense que c'est pas acceptable
hier sommet européen qui va
en parler en particulier à eux par
semaine prochaine ses recettes pour 100
euros penser que les choses vont
vraiment bougé entre chefs d'état ce
que je sens
au niveau des ministres et j'étais ya
quelques jours avec les mises des
finances
je consens niveau de chaque état ces
cas ce nouvel état d'esprit ce
volontarisme
tout pays tous les pays étudiés
les etats-unis le royaume-uni la france
l'allemagne
ce sujet
je pense qu'il va progresser comme
rarement même si les choses ont été
engagé après la crise notamment
je le rappelle par nicolas sarkozy
émana mercader le plan obama je pense
qu'il ya un nouvel élan qui a donné à
cette lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
alors justement votre collègue
commissaire européen se mettait à
parler même d'un délit et il a dit
qu'en 2015 dans moins de deux ans et
moins
il est l'objectif c'est de ne plus avoir
de secret bancaire anderson est-ce que
ces réaliste comme objectif 2015 quel
secret bancaire suisse n'est pas avec le
commissaire courageux
prends beaucoup d'initiatives que je
soutiens
leur maintien fiscalité est grand plus
d'harmonisation fiscale sur les sujets
qui intéressent les entreprises par
exemple
l'harmonisation des basses de l'impôt
sur les sociétés à l'intérieur du
même marché européen
elle est donc si je dis cela c'est que
je pense que une mise à l'elysée les
mots pour le dire qui il est qui est
surréaliste où il est si les questions
auprès de volonté
les deux dirigeants ne nous sentons
je sens cette nouvelle volonté
le but de mettre à bas
le ces paradis fiscaux
ils ont pensé que la commission
européenne peut avoir un mandat entre
l'hiver pour renégocier les accords que
c'est passé avec certains territoires
or union européenne comme monaco ou
totalement la suisse
deux sites celui qui peut répondre à
cette question
ce que je sens que c'est dans ce nouveau
mouvement qui s'engage
les pays de l'union européenne
qui pratiquent encore le secret bancaire
pour bouger les lignes bougent luxe en
bois déjà bougé
et que ces pays qui chantent dans
l'europe quelques fois
% en dehors de l'union
bourbon être amené à être dans ce
mouvement plutôt quand
cocon trouve en dehors de ce mouvement
donc vous avez une nouvelle marche de
l'économie mondiale notamment de la
vente
j'ai une voix une nouvelle marque
de cette moralisation générale
mais cette mise en ordre
mais ces nouvelles règles peine de quoi
avons-nous souffert depuis vingt ou
trente ans
dans ce grand vent ultralibérale il ya
souffler sur le monde entier que la
mondialisation
dates sont de règle plus de gouvernance
pas de supervision
des des banquiers qui se sont cru tout
permis ou plutôt à qui on a tous
permis des bonus insensés des produits
toxiques tout ça c'est fini je rappelle
que vont les jugeant ridicule au niveau
financier que je présentais 28 loi de
régulation depuis trois ans
la plupart arrivent à maturité en ce
moment
aucun marché financier aucun produit
financier
aucun acteur financier n'échappera à
la régulation publique alors justement
michel barnier erreur
nous avons interrogé 1 un trader
nous avons rencontré 400 ce qui n'est
pas en scène de tout ce ce mouvement de
la paix d'encadrement toute cette
réglementation engagé pour lutter
contre les dérives de la finance ils
ont eu du mal à rencontrer les accepter
de témoigner mais pas le visage couvert
écoutez son témoignage il vous faudra
réagir juste après
il tient le haut de l'affiché comme
après le double-attentat hier score
d'olivier course dans le filet
- frites
manipulateur sans scrupules motivée
uniquement par l'appât du gain
le trader
cinéma
dans la réalité pourtant pas facile de
l'aborder
marc trente-cinq ans a accepté de
témoigner il a travaillé pendant 10
ans pour de grandes banques à londres
et à paris il parle à visage couvert
y'a eu lieu sous les yeux
un fantasme soit près de deux heures
qui ont suivi
le défilé des voitures de luxe
au-delà de la corée du nord
une fois au score très véloce
quelqu'un qui va arriver trouve
maintenant en fabriquant sa journée en
allant vers 6h du matin
le réquisitoire tout ce qu'il faut qui
se prépare à ce que de gaulle marché
gourmand donc il faut plus
il du travail
le joueur prépare le grand ouest
travailler pour gagner
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup trop pour
certains
le parlement européen a admis le hall
à sur les bonus en votant une loi
qui empêche les traders de recevoir une
prime supérieure à leurs salaires
ce que je veux faire un peu plus
pas ou peu applicable
viège budget de façon de contourner
sorte que vous avez un exemple simple
vous apparaîtrez d'euros
chorale ce que vous devez l'instar de 25
ans plus roulé en moyenne touché 150
bureaux de vote
donc puisque se passer c'est si les
ventes ont limité à 100 % d'autres ont
dû batailler
on avance que la ferté-bernard doublure
de saverne c'est un corps sans vie de
retraité @ le ventoux son vélo bonus
en 2009 les grands de ce monde réunis
à londres ont promis de réguler la
finance et en interdisant ou en limitant
le recours à certaines pratiques
d'où l'urgence de l'argent pour
financer de grandes gueules surement
six mois uniquement la france ne valent
pas mieux européenne
c'est comprend qu'il faut faire honneur
à singapour hong kong ou remuant
pourtant dans le cadre du g20
poursuivant que du vent dans les
plantations et bulut plus grands centres
financiers le faire savoir
pourquoi
agent de l'ombre le traiteur est avant
tout un opérateur de marché qui
achète et vend des produits pour le
compte de son employeur
pour illustration
demandé à emmanuel dufour qui a très
bien géré la situation et la chine
plus facile des bénéfices pour que
votre assurance-vie
puis ceux à avoir un effet c'est tout
propre sang les larmes devant moi
ces dernières années des réformes ont
été lancées pour remettre les acteurs
de la finance au service de l'économie
mais les pratiques ont-elles vraiment
changé
merde
or c'est terrible ce qui veut dire
sur streller en plus et que c'est votre
dossier c'est vous qui avait limité les
bonus le dvd des banquiers et des
traders amende de de salaire
en fait ce qu'il dit c'est que ça sert
à rien
comment vous comment vous pouvez
entendre ça
d'abord je connais beaucoup de gens qui
s'élève à 7 heures du matin avez-vous
même parfois plutôt des ouvriers et
des paysans qui n'est pas 50 millions
paris qui sont très très très loin de
gagner
ce que le dernier smartphone
dans dans certaines places financières
ce que nous avons voulu
encadré
c'est pas pour pénaliser dit-il des
banquiers qui font leur boulot
le général mangou lire correctement
c est de limiter la prise de risque
car dans cette crise financière qui est
venu des etats-unis en avril et des
banquiers
être d'autant plus payés par des bonus
qui est le premier plus de risques
quand thierry ce que mettait leurs
banques en difficulté qu'est-ce qui t'a
et les risques les contribuables ça
suffit
donc nous voulons
interdire cette prise de risque en tout
cas la maîtriser
moi je pense que la mesure
quand je vois à quel point il était
convaincu
alors vite par le parlement européen
que j'ai soutenu
je pensais de mesures va produire des
effets
inédit
pour augmenter notre homme votre salaire
principal comme ça on va détourner
oui sauf que
moi je vais présenter un autre texte à
la fin de cette année qui va
responsabiliser les actionnaires
pour hassan de rémunérations les plus
élevées
d'une manière générale les
actionnaires soient responsabilisés
pour fixer
eux-mêmes et prendre la responsabilité
salaires qui paye
dans l'entreprise en question
actionnaires qui est de la transparence
si on verra bien ainsi au bout de la
route
tous ces gens continuent à vouloir
détourner à son profit des
actionnaires ont le sentiment que le
fait de payer beaucoup
les créateurs
ça va leur permettre à eux de gagner
beaucoup en dix ans dividende à ce que
j'ai envie de dire ils sont pas un peu
du du même bord que j'ai regardé le
mouvement qui s'est engagé qu'on a pu
le printemps des actionnaires on voit un
peu partout les compris
dans la grande place financière
européenne qui est londres
à paris à 30 fort
des actionnaires qui veulent prendre
leurs responsabilités
qui n'acceptent plus n'importe quoi
qu'elle a quelque peu de soi je sois
décidé en dehors d'eux
donc je pense que ce mouvement général
d'encadrement
il était nécessaire encore une fois
non pas pour empêcher les marchés
financiers de fonctionner
et pour les grands maîtres
au service de l'économie réelle
au service de des entreprises et des
territoires plutôt que d'être leur
propre service
en gagnant le match et me de profits
dans le minimum de temps élargissement
concrètement comment peut-on faire ça
parce qu'on a l'impression en écoutant
ce ce traiteur
cet opérateur de marché que m le
trader a toujours un train d'avancé sur
les institutions comment est-ce que
bruxelles peut faire pour remettre tout
le monde au pas pour remettre ces
acteurs-là au service de l'économiste
l'annoncé gens revenir à l'objet de
respecter les lois européennes qui vont
s'appliquer aux qui s'appuie des gens
les règles sur la capitalisation des
banques sur la limitation des bonus
sur les ratios de liquidité
les règles sur la transparence
concernant les produits dérivés ces
paravents tunisie les grands patrons et
qui s'applique à partir de maintenant
les produits dérivés kepu tunisienne
ces gens
ce qui d'ailleurs n'aime pas beaucoup la
lumière de nous sommes en train de
mettre de la lumière
sur chacun d'entre eux
ce sont 600 mille milliards écoutez-moi
bien assis sur mille milliards de
dollars de transactions
qui était pour 80% d'entre elles
sous la table
au volant de grandeur
c'est à dire de gré à gré
nous allons obliger
nous obligeons maintenant les
américains font la même chose
un enregistrement de cette transaction
donc partout l'areq ça va être
transparence
responsabilité
régulation mais finalement remettre de
la morale si je puis dire
là où il avait disparu des cantines
10%
mais bon ok on va pas le faire à
londres ni à paris parce que ça sera
interdit par l'europe et du coup ça va
se faire en comble
une décision à la hâte
il faut pas beaucoup de philanthropique
le voulez de rappeler
néanmoins le marché européen reste le
principal marché du monde
le 500 millions de dôngs consommateurs
22 millions d'entreprises au stade
marché
si le vol
être là ils sont au jeu d'être là
qui veut l'utiliser sans bouger de venir
chez nous et donc il a plutôt aguerris
parallèlement
nous travaillons niveau du g20
pour que ces règles européennes nous
ont parfois un peu d'avancé
nous les fassions parallèlement avec
les américains avec les chinois
étaient brésiliens avec les indiens
c'est un engagement montbrial
celui du g20 de remettre de l'ordre dans
la finance un outil sont aussi peut
être sur une autre avancée européenne
importante l'union bancaire privée du
coup travailler
j'y travaille encore également elle se
met en place progressivement une
question très concrète pour le citoyen
qui nous regarde ne manquèrent saikuar
est ce que c'est là la garantie que ces
dépôt seront pas assurées demain en
cas de de nouvelles crises bancaires une
chose qui est clair c'est que les
dépôts en dessous de 100 mille euros
partout
ben pour tous
une durablement pour préserver et
protéger c'est le cas aujourd'hui
via une directive européenne en cas de
faillite
parce qu'on a décoché trois s'étaient
pas tout à fait clair qu'on sait que
vous êtes et sont poursuivis pour
ould khattry tt la honte
le la loi européenne s'applique même
si j'ai eu un problème de communication
j'étais heureux qu'on puisse garantir
à chypre comme partout ailleurs
les dépôts au dessous
de 200000 euros pb les nombreux cas
c'est bien autre chose que ça
c'est la supervision les 6000 banques
européennes par la banque centrale
européenne dans la zone euro
eux-mêmes manuel de régulation
et de supervision
les mêmes règles qui s'appliquent
partout ça c'est aussi une leçon que
nous tirons de la crise que les banques
soient bien supervisé parce que ça a
été une crise de la supervision cette
crise financière et puis nous ajoutons
ce qu'on appelle la résolution
c'est dire pour chacune des grandes
banques l'obligation de préparer le
café chaud une faillite
pour que la fête soit randonnée
plutôt que de laisser arriver dans la
crise
il faille deux en donner qu'on demande
aux contribuables de payer moi je ne
veux plus que lui contribuable paye pour
les banques c'est vraiment plaisant où
ils payent pour les banques
on a vu que certains eneurope je crois
que ce secteur de
les allemands disent
ok ce sont mille euros c'est bien mais
en fait c'est pas suffisant
il faudrait carrément que l'ensemble
des commentaires quelque soit la somme
soit soit garanti est-ce que c'est
possible d'abord est-ce que ça peut
fonctionner
actuellement au-delà de cent mille
euros
le les dépôts bancaires ne sont pas
garanties
kuka critiques se passer n'importe quoi
d'ailleurs on a utilisé les dépôts
au-dessus de 100 milles
à chypre ce que je crois c'est que les
choses soient tous annoncée
transparente clairement d'affiché
pour sanctionner leurs créanciers et
déposants d'une banque
s'agissant de cette banque
à l'été ils font confiance ce à quoi
ils peuvent s'attendre
s'il y a
des difficultés je suis aussi favorable
à la préférence
des déposants c'est-à-dire que les
dépôts bancaires
même au dessus de 100 milles
soit les derniers appelés
ankara de faillite
et donc c'est ce que nous discutons et
qui misaient finance actuellement
alors michel barnier la commission
européenne que vous représentez
chargé
elle aussi de veiller au bon
fonctionnement du du marché européen
certaines pratiques qui ont pourtant
courante l'allemagne fait notamment
appel un des envoyés à venir des pays
de l'est ce qui travaillent dans des
conditions très difficile vous allez
voir avec ces happenings des
télévisions européennes
serge
un tracteur de l'état-major cité
troyenne afp à perdu son travail il ya
trois mois depuis il n'a reçu aucune
indemnité
son employeur une entreprise qui
fabrique de la soukra ne répond pas à
ces courriers ce n'est pas un cas isolé
des roumains des polonais et des
hongrois connaissent le même sort et
60% des personnels de l'industrie de la
viande à vienne des pays d'europe
centrale et orientale ils viennent
chercher le travail qu'ils ne trouvent
pas chez eux en séance dans le rouge
interdiction de filmer dans l'abattoir
mais aux abords du site on le voit les
travailleurs sont surtout humains et
bulgares
il travaille 60 heures par semaine de
jour comme de nuit pour trois à quatre
roues de leur talent
les employés
alors pourquoi ce matin m
pour accéder je dois pas d'apprécier
ap
- des pirates de l'air même
irene a frappé les deux tiers des
salariés ici viennent de la surface au
mali
pologne hongrie bulgarie ils sont payés
en moyenne 700 seront par mois c'est
trois fois moins que l'italie en pleine
tête
en effet
si l'entreprise emploie directement et
salariés elle le perd en moyenne 15
euros de l'heure dont 5 de charges soit
10 euros pour le salarié
or elle fait appel à des sous-traitants
moins cher 10 euros de l'heure ceux-ci
emploient à leur tour des salariés
déduisent à leur tour charge des
marges au bout du compte l'intérimaire
essayé pour mieux
4 euros de l'heure
elle m'inspire que de la nouvelle et
l'allemagne ouvre largement ses portes
aux travailleurs roumains se fait vite
répandue dans le pays le conducteur de
travail un découpeur de guillaume canet
gilles gagné plus de 1000 euros par
mois disponible publiés
il n'a pas le choix on est obligé
d'aller voir à l'étranger comment
prendre quelques risques qui se pressent
pour déposer leur cv doit savoir que le
travail est très difficile puisqu'il
faut être capable d'équiper apporter
en 15 minutes chrono 2004
il savait comment vous réagissez à cet
ensemble reportage ce qu'il est normal
de voir de
telles pratiques au sein de l'union
européenne notamment
dans la première économie en europe
européen cge réagi en publiant une
conviction que j'ai depuis longtemps
dès que je suis revenue à la
commission ce qu'il faut
que l'europe sociale progresse
qui est une union sociale jours
crédible qui accompagnent
l'union monétaire
l'union économique l'union bancaire
privée confidentielle
clairement il faut pas qu'il y ait dans
chaque pays
pas forcément au même niveau
à ces derniers mois me plier
à ces réunions dans chaque branche
déjà il ya des progrès qui ont été
faits
sur les conditions de travail de
sécurité au travail
on voit bien aussi qu'il a des pratiques
qui ne sont pas normal d'ailleurs nous
enquêtons sur certaines d'entre-elles
la map m la conclusion de ma réflexion
ce qu'il faut faire progresser
l'europe sociale en même temps que
notamment en mars en mars en danse en
passant pas samedi contre l'allemagne
dit qu'elle est dans la légalité ce
qui n'a pas de salaire minimum
le la commission a changé de position
depuis deux ou trois ans c'est aussi un
projet auquel j'ai contribué pour
demandez killer
dans chaque pays un salaire minimum
comme face à tout acte même salaire
minimum
en allemagne et en roumanie
mais au moins un salaire minimum et puis
dictée salaire minimum aussi par
branche
voilà voilà le progrès que nous
souhaitons et aucun autre yorick les
ministres est ce que c'est cette absence
de de rock social qui à votre avis
explique pour l'instant seules
désamour des européens partis au mans
des français d'ailleurs ce qui a eu un
sondage récent qui monte que là la
confiance dans l'europe telle qu'elle
est en train de se bâtir on est en
train de tomber de façon très
importante qu'est ce que vous en pensez
quand on voyait que les français
finalement aujourd'hui 10e pas ce que
bruxelles est donc la commission
européenne leur propose
c'est sans doute l'absence soulage
les insuffisances de l'europe sociale
des dossiers
plus généralement la crise où les
crises
comme jamais ont affronté il crée ton
show mage de difficulté pour les jeunes
de de colère ou ou de difficultés
sociales
donc le prolonge ça qui crée un climat
dans lequel sachant que d'hommes
politiques coup d'acteur
de l'économie
trouve commande de dire c'est la faute
de bruxelles
préfacé par bruxelles ni berlin qui a
obligé la france à ne pas avoir de
les budgets en équilibre de plus
le 37 ans
sherpa bruxelles ou
berlin qui
explique la france est une bête
équivalente à 94%
de son pays baissé à dire la richesse
d'une année voilà la dette des
français ce qui fait qu'on paye plus
pour notre dette que pour l'éducation
de nos enfants
ça c'est pour les autres c'est nous
il faut je pense qu'il ya des choses à
corriger a poussé moi je pense qu'il
faut changer l'europe
je suis revenu pour
participer à ce changement
et les nous vous le voyez bien
concrètement
nous le faisons la régulation
financière
le fil pour échanger vos questions le
plan social
le ce que je fais sur l'entrepreneuriat
social nous pûmes progression la ligne
bouge tout doucement
mais mais ça ne suffit pas
en revanche il faut aussi dans chaque
pays on assume ses responsabilités
et je pense aussi qu'il faut expliquer
pourquoi
l'om a besoin d'être ensemble
plutôt que chacun chez soi pourquoi il
faut être européen
en étant des patriotes parce que dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui
face à lui - à côté de la chine et
des etats-unis du brésil de l'inde dont
la russie si nous ne sommes pas ensemble
en août nous sommes en rapport de
l'écran nous sommes sous traitants
nous sommes sous son influence d autres
et moi j'ai pas envie que mon pays soit
sous influence sous-traitants et c'est
sans doute une raison d'espérer à
donner pour les citoyens européens qui
comptent berti vogts nazairienne dernier
merci peugeot